[Música]
la verdad es que desde pequeña tuve una
vida muy tranquila
nunca fue una prioridad para mí
preocuparme más allá de lo que había en
mi entorno
crecí con una idea en mi cabeza de ser
mejor y enorgullecer a las personas que
se encontraban en mi vida
una lucha constante conmigo misma decir
lo que algunos llaman correcto aunque
eso significará en el camino dejar atrás
ideas y sueños buscando sentirme
poderosa a veces en objetos a veces eran
personas situaciones y hasta acciones
las veces que tuve miedo las disfraces
de enojo
no podía concebir esa idea de el sexo
débil
y esto me llevó a ver un enemigo
constante en todo
hasta la que como yo estábamos pasando
por lo mismo
el no observar y analizar tu entorno te
lleva a ser demasiado egoísta y banal
con unos lentes que solo te dejan ver de
cerquita
tal como me pasó a mí
cuando comencé la universidad y una
clase en la que la verdad es que no era
nada buena
nos pidieron hacer una campaña
publicitaria enfocada en el tema que
nosotros nos sintiéramos cómodos
mis amigas y yo elegimos a un público
femenino
nos dijimos va a ser fácil nosotras
somos mujeres y claramente sabemos lo
que queremos
nuestro proyecto consistía en una línea
de perfumes y joyas donde el eslogan
sería
el poder de mujer
era básicamente una campaña donde las
joyas hacían alusión a como en ella se
radicaba el poder de la mujer
que salía en nuestra imagen publicitario
ya no usted ya los de no era una idea
muy buena y probablemente no nos
entregaría en el premio al esmero
pero la verdad es que estábamos
satisfechas con nuestro trabajo se
presentó se calificó y pues nada seguí
con mi vida sin cuestionarme más allá de
nada
no mentiré diciendo que me di cuenta en
ese instante que nuestro trabajo tenía
muchas cosas mal
y no me refiero tanto a las
características teóricas
la verdad es que no nos fue nada mal en
esa materia
sino en un análisis más allá de lo que
yo nunca nunca me había cuestionado en
la vida
cuando era chiquita como de unos 7 años
en mi salón de clases había una niña a
la que casualmente todo el mundo nos
decía que nos parecíamos un montón y no
creo que no era tanto en el físico sino
en las cosas que nos gustaban en cómo
hablábamos en cómo nos vestíamos
recuerdo que hasta teníamos una letra
super parecida jazz ellas desde una
súper raro
pero justo ni me molestaba muchísimo esa
idea
el compararme constantemente me enojaba
mucho
así que sin conocerla decidí hacerla mi
enemiga
así es así es enemigas a los siete años
cada vez que yo sentía que hace algo
mejor que ella me sentía realizada
poderosa
pero así un día de la nada la cambiaron
de escuela
tal vez y saber la razón pero la verdad
es que ahorita ni me acuerdo
cuando se fue me sentí súper rara como
si ella me diera la razón en ese momento
para sentirme satisfecha conmigo misma
los años pasaron y constantemente
buscaba otras cosas con las cuales
sentirme así
completa y buscando a veces en personas
a veces en objetos y a veces pensando
como joyas pueden dártelo
la verdad es que nunca pasó por mi mente
buscarlo en mí
tarde un tiempo en acomodar mis ideas y
en entender cómo el empoderamiento
femenino era un término que se podía
tomar a la subjetividad y transversal
con mucha mucha facilidad y les voy a
explicar por qué
ella estará al almería joven emiratí en
2016 fue nombrada jefa de consejo de
ciencias de los emiratos árabes unidos-
en 2017 fue nombrada para dirigir el
programa espacial de los emiratos y es
líder científica de la nación que tiene
este país a marte
por otro lado tenemos a leonora mente
ella es una joven alemana embaucada para
vivir en el autonombrado estado islámico
como una de las varias esposas de los
combatientes terroristas
donde vive un infierno rodeada de hambre
abusos y los estragos que conlleva una
guerra de esta naturaleza
una guerra civil que ni siquiera le
correspondía a ella
pero
que podrían diferenciar de estas dos
mujeres
tal vez tengan distintos contextos tal
vez tengan diferentes idiomas y vivan en
distintas realidades
pero la verdad es que no hay nada más
allá que las diferencias
el empoderamiento femenino no radica en
las buenas o malas decisiones que hemos
tomado a lo largo de la vida
tampoco radica en los grandes o pequeños
logros mucho menos radica en lo material
y es algo que la verdad es que no
terminamos de darnos cuenta
y parece que todo lo que nos rodea esté
enfocado en que sigamos en esta
confusión
no necesitamos ir muy lejos para darnos
cuenta de ello
basta con ver a las madres solteras que
día a día sacan adelante a su familia
siendo fuertemente criticadas este
sector es estigmatizado por la sociedad
mujeres expresando sus sentimientos de
forma libre y consciente
estás exagerando estás exagerando
muchísimo
mujeres manifestándose contra las
injusticias
qué les pasa estas locas están locas
mujeres dando opiniones profundas y bien
argumentadas
ay no pues a mí se me hace la verdad que
estás pensando demasiado las cosas
todos los días vivimos situaciones como
estas e incluso peores
todo esto muchas veces nos hace perder
la fe en nosotras mismas
y queremos encontrarlas en personas
objetos situaciones o incluso en el
silencio
con todo esto quiero expresar como el
término de empoderamiento femenino ha
estado definiendo se mal
y no la verdad es que mi intención no es
desacreditar la equidad de género
y minimizar los logros de mujeres
increíbles
a lo que me refiero es que el
empoderamiento femenino no está en las
oficinas del programa espacial emiratí
y tampoco está en una casa de irak
ni está en los grandes ni más mínimos
logros
así como tampoco está en los más caros
zapatos ni en la ropa más sofisticada
el poder está en nosotras mismas y en la
capacidad capacidad de visibilizar el
poder de las otras sin que el nuestro se
ve opacado en la lucha interna y con un
sistema que estamos cambiando y que
vamos a cambiar
y en saber lo valiosas que somos por el
hecho de aceptarnos y amarlos
quiero para mí
para las demás y para las que vienen un
mundo donde no tengamos miedo de salir a
buscar nuestro poder
y donde el miedo no sea algo que rija
nuestras vidas
quiere un lugar donde cada mujer se
sienta dueña de sí misma
quiero un lugar donde el miedo no sea
algo que definan nuestras vidas
la verdad es que no sé si nos falta
mucho o poco para lograrlo lo que sí
tengo por seguro es que no vamos a
desistir
soñemos en grande aspiramos a más
crecemos con fuerza y ante la duda
siempre recordemos tenemos razón no
estamos solas
seamos este ruido tan necesario en este
silencio perpetuo que nos hemos guardado
[Música]